c'est la nouvelle émission événement
lancé pendant les vacances par m6 légaux
master's une émission enfantine animé
par eric antoine qui lors de sa première
diffusion le 23 décembre a su séduire
les fans de briques et de défis avec ce
format ludique adaptation tout droit
venu de grande-bretagne
la chaîne a réussi à rassembler 4
millions de téléspectateurs tout d'abord
au rebond sauf que voilà visiblement
dans lego masters il n'y a pas que les
briques qui se casse la gueule les
audiences aussi en seulement trois
numéros l'émission a connu une chute de
ses audiences vertigineuse seulement 2,5
millions de téléspectateurs soit 11% du
public pour le dernier numéro de
l'émission diffusée mardi soir je n'ai
jamais vu une meuf fame d'une pelle
violent même si la part d'audience
concernant la femme responsable des
achats de moins de 50 ans et au plus
haut avec 25%
ce résultat fait de m6 la quatrième des
audiences hier soir alors comprenez vous
pourquoi les goûts masters s'est
effondré alors non mais tu vas le
recevoir un message de défi de spider
bonne année s'accordant les chéris
j'oserais dire ça reste quand même un
succès et je dis pas alors on ici et là
qui m'ont livrée il dit ça parce que
c'est son groupe de production
franchement ça reste un succès les mecs
je pense qu m6 va en faire une deuxième
saison vous pourquoi 2 millions en 2005
sur m6 en prime c'est un très bon score
vous l'avez dit 25% ménagères c'est un
super score aussi mais je trouve que
c'est une super émission il ya un vrai
univers c'est très original j'adore les
léguer des vrais passionnés de lego en
plus c'est une vraie passion qu'ont
plein de gens je fonctionne super
émission et ça reste des bons scores
c'est vrai que c'est coloré c'est
impressionnant les matchs que c'était un
programme événementiel qui était bien
entre chapeau et la bûche vous pensez
que c'est bien sûr deux numéros
d'acteurs de numéro et pendant les
vacances de noël et efficace moi en tant
que maman je peux le regarder avec les
enquêtes sur la les enfants il bosse où
ils vont se coucher
donc du coup je pense que c'était malgré
tout un peu trop un peu trop long sinon
je trouve que c'est un très beau
programme c'était efficace et
intéressant il y avait un bon
storytelling et j'étais contente parce
que la structure finale sera exposée à
l'hôpital necker d un seul ipad est venu
ça c'est moi qui leur a coûté une barre
est là c'est que du bon donc la dernière
fois la tête de ma mère et il me dit
j'ai regardé une émission extraordinaire
chez moi nigauds nigauds nigauds
c'est quoi nico aligot et me dit ouais
j'ai regardé les nigauds j'ai kiffé ma
tête il bien fait mais moi ce que les
fans de lego et fois chaude
il a kiffé sa tête la marche politique
ça marche
ses fans d'eric antoine duce jetterait
pour lui que ça marche d'ailleurs j'ai
même fait beaucoup de postes sur les
réseaux sociaux pascal question
d'apprendre si tôt mais moi ce que je
pense c'est que ça a démarré fort mais
ensuite ça descende parce que c'était
beaucoup suivi par les enfants c'est
beaucoup les enfants qui attendaient le
lego et là les jeux sont très
compliquées pour les enfants moi je
penses tu as raison sur un truc c'est
que hier les enfants sont allés se
coucher plus tôt et et même les toits
sur moi je me couche je sais comme top
chef la victime jaguar la construction
jusqu'au bout en bout d'un moment je me
suis dit je regarderai le replay
d'accord et c'est vrai qu'à beaucoup
d'enfants qui sont couchés alors quand
il est né n'était pas en vacances
donc forcément il est le premier
smartphone à la vacance que ma collègue
de travail défini et moi j'ai pas
l'impression que ce soit un programme
vraiment de de vacances et je trouve
qu'il ya des adultes aussi qu'ils sont
passionnés par les l'urgent c'est le
rappeur leur enfance
y'a pas une courageuse jour ne trouve
pas que ce soit que ça que ça ait baissé
alors que dieu vous dire aussi ce n'est
pas tout c'est que pendant les vacances
de noël et pendant le mois de décembre
je voulais dit la semaine dernière un
facho des nues en début de semaine c'est
que sur 7 sur ce segment là y'a pas des
programmes très très fort sur les autres
chaînes toutes les chaînes comme il ya
très très peu de pub les rentrées
publicitaires et très peu de rentrées
d'argent dit toutes les chaînes
commerciales
elle est franchement on va dire assez
liquidation totale tout ce qu'ils ont
pas mis pendant l'année ils essaient de
le tenter là et il voit si ça marche ça
marche ça marche pas tant pis et donc
légaux masters avaient une plus faible
concurrence
hier soir il avait une concurrence
privée soit et mine de rien sur tf1
mardi soir de tf1
il avait une fiction inédite sur
françois gabart idrissa de fabien
onteniente et la bio qui a cartonné 1
100 % bio il avait les pouvoirs
extraordinaires du corps humain lui mine
de rien sur france 2 c'est annie les
villes a fait deux millions et demi et
surtout il avait tout la tnt parce qu'il
faut savoir que toutes les chaînes de
tnt
pendant les vacances 15 décembre les
chaînes tnt c'est au lido il diffuse
plus rien même nous ils avaient
tellement rien là diffusée sur m6 c'est
la première fois que ça arrive dans
l'histoire
ils ont re diffusés en prime à dix jours
des quarts
ils ont en effet la semaine d'après
tromper mais les gens verront rien
t'inquiète t'inquiète pas donc voilà
donc c'est vrai que voilà hier par
exemple s'est vite a cartonné avec plus
d'un million de téléspectateurs avec
évasion de y aura d'ailleurs évasion 3
la semaine prochaine il y aura et vases
aux quatre ultimes moments ils sont en
train de tourner et on va le mettre
direct 8 oui bonsoir bonsoir
l'opération s'est bien passée vous
cherchez déjà là maintenant alors en
plus à une cible qui est extrêmement
difficile à aller chercher aujourd'hui
qui est ultra sollicité qui sont les
jeunes et jason de plus en plus
sollicité avec les différents écrans
donc clairement effectivement ça deux ça
aurait dû être un peu plus événementiel
et je pense que deux numéros aurait
suffi mais surtout effectivement ce sont
les enfants qui sont prescripteurs sont
se laisser convoquer les jeux sont donc
de là il hier soir s'était terminée là
les colas ont pris des arrêtés 45 donc
vous avez la fal l'aménageur et renard
mais je vais vous dire isabelle je vais
vous expliquer quelque chose machine ça
marche pas elle vient de dire 35% sur
les jeunes
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi le
chiffre a baissé parce que 35% sur les
jeunes oui oui un pourcentage mais étant
donné qu'à - john dalli john quant au
nombre ça fait beaucoup moins parler
vrai et comment sur les chiffres oui
c'est vrai les chiffres j'irai jamais
vous chercher là dessus moi c'est pas
nul ah non sur la ménagère je voudrais
la direction c'est très content ce matin
mais tout le monde est content mais a
oui vous regardez l'exemple sur la
ménagère on est passé de 30 à 25 %
donc on perd quand même six points
pourquoi on perd 6 points parce que hier
il y avait il y avait aujourd'hui il y
avait école donc vermont la ménagère et
les enfants n'étaient plus loin d'être
placée en moi c'est surtout jamais
leaders soient bien sûr il y avait une
concurrence qui était mary bien bien
plus important quand même lanvin un
enfant de star hierà dans ligue au
masters l'enfant de stars de greg
guillotin qu'on adore un bien sûr notre
gaye qui nous prépare un truc de fou je
vous le dis et à l'enfant de stars de el
profesor de la casa des papes elle
regarde c'est vraiment l'enfant de stars
degré guillotin et de du professeur
alors les chérir encore un numéro la
semaine prochaine ce sera le dernier
je pense comme 6 mars signé parce que ça
reste des scores très très haut pour
nicolas pernikoff ya pas de problème
et aucun problème et puis ça a surtout
c'est un programme de grande qualité un
gars bien produit je suis désolé et une
des critiques sur le jury gyma si on va
reparler un peu mais n'auront que le
jury justement sont les passionnants
mais ce sont les passionnés puis je suis
désolé le programme est d'une grande
qualité moi regarder ces théories sont
bienveillants que j'étais bien moi je
suis passionné de les gourmands mais
surtout je suis exposé le monde et
créateur hors pair un jeu c'est moche à
densifier par allah par la marque
bien sûr vous êtes certifié par un m
radio est-ce qu'il veut cloclo qu'est-ce
qu'ils veulent est sûre le plan d'action
exactement ils sont faits un peu embêté
que le mot légaux parce que c'est perçu
comme d'ailleurs publicité ils ont plus
trop le droit de le dire à l'antenne
parce qu'en france il ya un vrai tabou
avec les marques les gosses est une
marque ses marques commerciales rousset
alors pardon aux états unis vous avez
plein de marques vous avez des émissions
de télé on dit pas tout de suite la
séquence avait joué avec du plastique
non il rappelé à l'ego mais ils peuvent
pas trop le dire à l'antenne parce que
j'ai perçu comme de la publicité
d'accord moi c'est le premier truc
mondes m6 se passe kerry quand on
n'arrêtait pas de parler des briques je
ne pourrai plus par princesse de brix
emmerdant il m'a dit parce que on n'a
pas de partenariat avec lego et on veut
pas qu'on croit le contraire vous
décrire plusieurs marques de briquettes
et qu'on veut pas qu'elle pense qu'on a
un accord avec les messieurs le moins
sont impossibles